hola de nuevo bueno no sé si te has dado
cuenta pero soy un tanto obsesiva y he
estado haciendo varias demostraciones
sobre el famosísimo teorema de pitágoras
así que qué más da aquí va otro otro
otra demostración del teorema de
pitágoras y cómo y cómo inician estas
demostraciones siempre inician con el
dibujo de un triángulo rectángulo
entonces aquí está voy a dibujar un
triángulo rectángulo esta es la
hipotenusa la hipotenusa va a ser la
base del triángulo bueno simplemente va
a estar abajo y aquí uno de los catetos
el cateto más largo tiene longitud
y tenemos también el otro lado recuerda
que es un triángulo rectángulo entonces
más o menos ahí se forma un ángulo recto
y éste tiene longitud ve muy bien en
definitiva esto parece un triángulo
rectángulo y aquí le falta su ángulo
recto que dice que es un triángulo
rectángulo ahí está ahora lo que voy a
hacer es tomar este este triángulo
rectángulo y lo voy a rotar en sentido
contrario a las manecillas del reloj
entonces lo que voy a hacer es rotar
este triángulo en esta dirección y voy a
rotarlo en una medida de 90 grados
entonces eso eso va a provocar que la
hipotenusa que la hipotenusa quede así
totalmente vertical a la otra hipotenusa
entonces esa es la hipotenusa de nuestro
nuevo triángulo que va a ser totalmente
congruente a este y acá quedará la el
lado a que es totalmente horizontal al
lado b
así este es el cateto del triángulo
rectángulo y aquí se forma un ángulo
recto ángulo de 90 grados de hecho para
cada par de lados correspondientes se
forma un ángulo de 90 grados aquí entre
las dos hipotenusa también se forma un
ángulo de 90 grados y aquí falta dibujar
el lado que tiene longitud de este lado
tiene longitud b
y también no olvidemos aquí el ángulo de
90 grados lo que hice fue rotar este
triángulo en dirección contraria a las
manecillas del reloj en un ángulo de 90
grados ahora lo que quiero hacer es
formar con esto un paralelogramo y eso
lo voy a hacer aquí este es de longitud
aquí tiene longitud c ahora para formar
paralelogramo lo que haré decir de este
punto totalmente hacia arriba en
dirección vertical hasta aquí esto tiene
longitud c entonces este segmento tiene
longitud c y ahora voy a ir de este
punto de este punto a este punto que
longitud tiene eso a ver si puedes
adivinar qué longitud tiene esto de
hecho te daré una pista una pista esto
es un paralelogramo entonces este lado
es paralelo a este lado mantienen la
misma distancia eso quiere decir que
viaja en la misma dirección horizontal y
en la misma dirección vertical
manteniendo la distancia de los de los
lados así que eso quiere decir que este
lado también
idea pero aquí no se terminan las
preguntas porque la siguiente pregunta
que tengo para ti es la siguiente cuál
es el área de este paralelogramo para
pensar en eso voy a dibujar nuevamente
esta parte del diagrama este este es el
lado a lo voy a dibujar como que está
acostado sobre el suelo entonces estos
son de longitud y acá están los lados de
longitud
este y este son de longitud cm ahora
observa de este lado te da la pista
porque este lado es la altura es la
altura del paralelo gramos y tú si tú
observas bien este lado es totalmente
perpendicular a la base del
paralelogramo entonces la altura del
paralelo gramo es anti de longitud
y cuál es el área del paralelogramo para
calcular el área de un paralelogramo
simplemente es base por altura así que
tenemos entonces que el área de este
paralelogramo es al cuadrado y ok ya con
esto hagamos lo mismo pero rotemos
rotemos nuestro triángulo original en la
otra dirección así que vamos a rotar los
90 grados en la dirección de las
manecillas del reloj entonces partimos
desde este punto y que obtenemos con
esto este lado este lado de longitud se
sale se rota hacia este lado entonces
sale de aquí
y lo intento hacer lo mejor posible a
escala entonces ahí ese tiene longitud
se ahora este lado de longitud de brotar
entonces sale de la figura así es
paralelo al lado hay ahí se forma un
ángulo recto ok excelente excelente
entonces después qué sucede luego el
lado de longitud
queda justo aquí este es un lugar
entonces este lado mide a este lado me
deben de hecho bbva en azul voy a
ponerlo en su color entonces ve acá da a
cada uno lo que le corresponde aquí hay
un ángulo recto y yo que ya todo en su
lugar perfecto entonces vamos a
construir otro otro paralelogramo aquí
baja perfecto que entonces esto me
deseen esto estoy acá mide mi deber y
también estará do mide ve usando la
misma lógica vamos a construir
paralelogramo son líneas paralelas
avanza lo mismo en dirección horizontal
y lo mismo en dirección vertical
entonces ya con esto otra vez la misma
pregunta cuál es el área de este
paralelogramo una vez más para
visualizarlo voy a dibujarlo como si
estuviera en el piso como si estuviera
han sentado entonces este es un lado
baja a un lado b es ese lado y acá
tenemos el otro lado b que sería el que
está arriba ahora am ahora los lados es
aquí son estos esto es si esto es
perfecto cuál es su altura su altura es
ésta está aquí entonces esta es su
altura tiene longitud p sabemos que esto
mide 90 grados este ángulo que se forma
ahí también esté aquí también hay un
ángulo recto porque hicimos una rotación
de 90 grados así lo construimos ahora
para encontrar el área de un
paralelogramo es base por altura así que
por lo tanto tenemos que este
paralelogramo tiene
debe al cuadrado y aquí se pone
interesante el asunto lo que haría
continuación es copiar y pegar este esta
parte de la figura ajá porque para mí es
lo más importante del diagrama que que
hemos construido aquí así que lo
seleccionó lo mejor posible
lo copió entonces creo que ya está bien
creo que está bien y ahora a copiar
voy a bajar un poco la pantalla para
tener espacio para lo que haré a
continuación y entonces copiar y pegar
y allí tenemos el diagrama que hemos
construido y se ve muy claro cuál es su
área cierto yo creo que se ve muy claro
cuál es su área borraré algunas partes
para que hay no hay mejor en color negro
ok entonces ya borró algunas partes para
tener mejor enfoque de lo que queremos y
cuáles a cuáles aunque también voy a
borrar aquí esto
y voy a borrar de hecho también sería
muy bueno borrar esta parte perfecto ok
entonces voy a borrar eso aunque sabemos
que tiene longitud sé no olvides eso eso
tiene longitud se y esa parte la voy a
dibujar acá arriba bajada sabemos que
por construcción eso también me desee
entonces esperado también me dice pero
lo borren ahora sabemos que la altura
ese y me pregunta para ti la siguiente
cuál es el área de esta figura bueno es
simplemente al cuadrado más b al
cuadrado cierto lo voy a escribir el
área es al cuadrado más p al cuadrado y
ese es el área de los dos para logramos
juntos ahora bien cómo podemos
reacomodar hacer un reacomodo a estas
piezas de tal forma de tal manera que lo
expresemos en términos de ce y tal vez
tú te diste cuenta cuando yo dibujé acá
esta línea bueno sabemos que que este
lado me dice lo voy a escribir en blanco
esto esto me dice y eso es una gran
pista ahora haiga donde fue mi figura
acá está está perfecto se había perdido
del diagrama entonces esta longitud es
lo que podemos hacer es lo siguiente
tomar este triángulo este triángulo el
cual es totalmente congruente a nuestro
triángulo original
y bajarlo entonces vamos a hacer eso
hagamos eso voy a tomar esto voy a
copiar y ponerlo aquí
entonces bueno de hecho voy a cortarlo
lo voy a cortar y bueno todo a todo este
triángulo entonces lo que hago es cortar
y pegarlo y lo pego entonces aquí queda
abajo lo que hice fue reacomodar el área
de al cuadrado más b al cuadrado y nos
queda este cuadrado el cual tiene área
de al cuadrado más b al cuadrado está
área amarilla es a la otra área azul es
b y entonces antes esto era un
paralelogramo simplemente baje el
triángulo y mágicamente se convierte en
un cuadrado
esto tiene área b entonces mi pregunta
es qué qué es esto en términos de c
todo esto tiene área sea al cuadrado
porque es un cuadrado con bases e y
alturas así que tiene esto es igual a
sea al cuadrado y una vez más hemos
probado el famosísimo teorema de
pitágoras